obviously he did have a webcam business  and from what I understand that was many  years ago although perhaps there is  something to do with only fans which has  been a little bit more recent but when  you do work in that line of business  you're going to get these levels of  accusations it's no surprise to me it's  as they say play stupid games Win stupid  prizes and that's what happens the  webcam business you know managing women  only fans and things like that isn't  illegal but like I said obviously when  you do work in these kind of areas and  you work with women Andrew was walking a  very fine line working in that kind of  industry